parc aquatique water wizz construit à l'
été 83 son dernier bastion de
tout ce que cette période représentait en
fait il a été décrété par son créateur à
cet endroit ne vieillira jamais sur son
lit de mort il a dit je ne veux pas que cet endroit se
repente ou mis à jour le fer  veux être
mis au code à la minute où quelqu'un
essaie d'être détruit il a en fait une
bombe nucléaire pour une telle occasion
pourri les Russes vraiment tu es toujours
bon avec tout ça même la
chose russe qui est la guerre froide son genre de daté
bien merci ça  a été gaspillé,
hé hé, un enfant a vomi presque fou
aussi pourquoi est-ce la première fois que j'entends parler
de cette [ __ ] de femme Caitlin Duncan
Tony Barry ceinture hé Duncan aussi j'ai besoin que
vous réorganisiez plus de cartes a-t-il terminé
le calendrier de travail pour  la semaine prochaine est-ce que ça a
changé tous les filtres aucun donc tu sais que
je vais bien vérifier tout
ça dans ce cas je n'ai rien fait de
bien alors je le fais ça s'appelle
délégation bébé j'ai lu dans le livre
à ce sujet  que  C'est celle que tu attends mon
homme oh ouais a-t-elle regardé en arrière, elle
m'aime bien